y siete médicos peruanos de la ciudad de
piura hacen parte de un extraño caso de
contagios porque hoy 19 todos
contrajeron el virus luego de haber
recibido la primera dosis de la vacuna
contra el virus los médicos hacen parte
de la primera etapa de vacunación
iniciada en perú el 9 de febrero con
dosis de la farmacéutica china sino farm
esta primera ronda estaba dirigida al
personal de salud militares bomberos y
adultos mayores es importante decir que
los tres médicos que están en la unidad
de cuidados intensivos habían recibido
solamente la primera dosis y luego se
infectaron no llegaron a completar la
segunda dosis los otros 4 médicos que
completaron la segunda dosis se
contagiaron antes de los 15 días de la
segunda vacunación
por ahora la farmacéutica estatal china
y el instituto de productos biológicos
de beijing no se han pronunciado
respecto a este caso pero las
autoridades sanitarias de perú han dicho
desde el principio que las personas
inmunizadas no están libres de
infectarse en algún momento la vacuna
china tiene una efectividad del 79 por
ciento es un atenuante de formas graves
de contagio por coronavirus disminuyen
su propagación pero no evita que el
inmunizado se enferme pero no para de
superar récords de contagios y muertes
por kobe 19 el sábado se reportaron casi
300 fallecidos en 24 horas apenas dos
días después de que batiese su propio
récord de contagios diarios con casi 13
mil reportados en un mismo día la
velocidad de los contagios se ha visto
alentada con la expansión descontrolada
de las variantes británica y brasileña
del coronavirus ampliamente extendidas
en el país